madame monsieur bonsoir la trajectoire
capricieuse d'un astéroïde venant
alimenter au passage les grandes peurs
du millénaire inquiété jusqu'à cette
nuit les scientifiques mais fort
heureusement cet immense cailloux lourde
d'un milliard de tonnes à dévier sa
route et ne viendra pas foulé la terre
le 26 octobre 2000 28 comme l'avait
prévu un groupe d'astronomes voici le
scénario auquel on a échappé hiver
nucléaire et raz-de-marée géant après
l'impact
elisabeth les flets le choc des planètes
est un fantasme vieux comme le monde qui
a inspiré les cinéastes et de science
fiction et nous inquiéter le temps d'un
vendredi 13 et d'une simple vérification
de calcul voici donc un astéroïde repéré
par les américains d'un milliard de
tonnes et d'un kilomètre et demi de
diamètre
il aurait pu venir frôler la terre en
2038 certains scientifiques imaginait
déjà de le dérouter à coups d'armes
nucléaires de fait 1997
x est foncée son nom passera très loin
de nous et n'est déjà plus qu'un mauvais
souvenir
on a pu calculer leur métal beaucoup
plus de précision est l'objet passé
alain 169 km des naissains donc trois
fois la distance terre-lune donc il ya
aucun problème d collision avec la terre
vingt mille astéroïdes sont en mouvement
dans l'espace mais loin d'une il y
aurait quand même eu des chocs la
disparition des dinosaures seraient dus
à la collision d'un énorme caillou avec
la terre plusieurs siècles avant notre
ère les chinois ne paie déjà le passage
des planètes
depuis toujours elles sont du sinistre
présage bien que leur passage n'ai
jamais entraîné de catastrophe
mais le ciel continue à faire peur je
reste mais sérieux d'autres pas les
récits les récits que comment dirais-je
de fin du monde contre eux dans
l'apocalypse uns parlent des étoiles qui
tombe du ciel le ciel vous dépasse
infiniment et par conséquent on peut
tout espérer de lui mais peut-être aussi
tout craindre
une croyance populaire veut que les
changement de millénaire génère toutes
les angoisses mais selon les historiens
celle de l'an mil n'ont pas existé et
celle de l'an 2000 sont encore à venir
l'année prochaine